instead of trying to convince the other
person or persuade the other person
listen help them empty their heart and
express why they're frustrated with a
situation and then they'll be more
likely to listen to your own experiences
and more receptive to why you think
climate change
matters and is relevant today on shock
radio
we're exploring climate action and how
one nonprofit is providing a framework
for young people
to help affect change the thing about
teaching young people
in particular is that young people are
open-minded
to new material but they're mature
enough to understand fairly complex
concepts
ultimately we hope that ambassadors will
teach students
students will teach families and
families will demand action
i'm your host sarah hansen with us today
is brandon lachinsky
a graduate student in the technology and
policy masters program
and the aeronautics and astronautics
masters program at mit
brandon's also working with a non-profit
called earth dna
if this organization sounds familiar to
you it's because our last guest
professor of astronautics deva newman
co-founded earth dna it's a global
platform for climate advocacy
and action our guest today
brandon helps create a program called
earth dna
ambassadors which provides young people
with climate leadership
training in addition to learning about
the science behind climate change
ambassadors also develop skills focused
on communication
negotiation and storytelling
we envision a community of climate
leaders
who engage their own communities on
their campuses
at their schools on climate change
current ambassadors
come from different backgrounds whether
phd students in immunology
or undergraduate students in business
some of them have teaching experience
but not all of them
[Music]
one of the tools that earth dna equips
their ambassadors with
is called climate 101
available on mit open courseware and
earthdna.org
it's an interactive workshop that was
designed to engage communities around
climate change
and motivate people to act but changing
human behavior can be difficult
so climate 101 starts with something a
bit more approachable
the power of conversation well i think
talking about it is really important
because i think that
climate change has the stigma about it
where if you
even bring it up you're viewed as you
know
a hippie environmentalist and alarmists
and all these things
and so even by having conversations
about it and making it normal to have
conversations
about climate change you empower others
to do that as well and
that's huge because for a lot of people
they just don't hear about climate
change that often
or if they hear about it it's not
necessarily the best information
and so if we can have people talking
about climate change in a way that's
personal and meaningful
to their family members who might be
climate skeptics
that's one of the best ways to create
the attitude
and behavioral change that's necessary
to actually overcome
the problem of climate change in
addition to normalizing discussions on
climate change
the climate 101 presentation is designed
to improve
climate literacy that means empowering
people to think critically about climate
change data
and research and even targeted marketing
campaigns
one of the things that we actually talk
about in the climate 101 workshop
is the effect of different
information campaigns by fossil fuel
companies
who have a very clear interest in
preventing any kind of climate action
and in promoting misinformation among
the public promoting doubt among the
public
about whether climate change happens
it's really important for me
that people are able to sift through all
that competing information
in order to decide for themselves
whether climate change is real whether
it matters
to them and whether they should do
something about it
now i think the answer to all three of
those questions is yes
but i want to help people process this
deluge of information by themselves and
be aware
that there are people that are
intentionally trying to misinform them
climate literacy is critical to efforts
for creating a grassroots movement of
climate change
action brandon sees the earth dna
ambassadors
who are between the ages of 16 and 30 as
the next generation of climate leaders
and educators
the thing about teaching young people in
particular
is that young people are open-minded to
new material
but they're mature enough to understand
fairly complex concepts
they're also part of their parents
trusted networks so if we can talk to
young people
they can talk to their parents
ultimately we hope that
ambassadors will teach students students
will teach families
and families will demand action
ultimately i think in creating earth dna
ambassadors
i was really interested in helping
people who are passionate about climate
change
find their own voice and helping them to
express
their own beliefs and their own opinions
and
make a change in their own community i
think empowering people
who care about climate change to find
their voice and use it
has been one of the most rewarding
things that i've done and i'm just
really grateful for the opportunity
to be part of this community of people
that are
all interested in self-development in
leadership and in climate change
in putting the climate 101 presentation
together
brandon and the earth dna team didn't
want to entirely reinvent the wheel
they were open to utilizing many
different materials from a variety of
reputable sources
to create a comprehensive experience for
participants
and part of what makes it so effective
is that the presentation has been
developed to appeal to a wide audience
whether you're a high school student or
a late career professional
so most climate change educational
materials focus
almost exclusively on the science while
climate 101
covers in 45 minutes the science the
economics and the civics of climate
change
and what that allows us to do is to
engage with people who wouldn't
typically consider climate change to be
one of their first priorities
the idea was to create a single
composition that keeps people's
attention
that keeps people engaged that keeps
people interested and excited
while also sharing a large amount of
information about climate change from
different perspectives
and i think that's what climate 101 has
accomplished
and earth dna has data to back that up
surveys they've collected
show that before the presentation about
half of the students talked with their
friends or family about climate change
twice a week but afterward the number of
people participating in those
conversations
jumped to over 80 percent sometimes
those conversations can be difficult
especially when they're with people who
are skeptical about climate change
but climate 101 helps ambassadors with
that too
when it comes to climate change even the
stories of what's happening
is very different right we have
different interpretations
of different facts that lead us to
different conclusions
and then we often argue about those
conclusions without understanding each
other's interpretations or the
observations that each of us have made
and so even in bringing up a climate
change conversation
you have to be aware that you might be
threatening the way that somebody sees
themselves
or maybe in engaging in these
conversations you are threatening
somebody's sense of patriotism
or sense of being a good person
especially in areas where the economy is
based in
fossil fuels it can be really difficult
because ultimately a climate change
conversation
can amount to an accusation that that
person is not just
providing food for their family but also
is damaging the earth and
harming a lot of people and so it's
really important to consider all of
those
things as you have these climate change
conversations
so instead of trying to convince the
other person or persuade the other
person
listen help them empty their heart
and express why they're frustrated with
a situation and then they'll be more
likely to listen to your own experiences
and more receptive to why you think
climate change
matters and is relevant
[Music]
something else that helps the climate
101 presentation resonate across
different audiences
is the incorporation of local insights
this targeted approach helps distill the
larger sometimes overwhelming issue of
climate change
into something more digestible one of
the problems with climate change
discussions is that it's a huge problem
right it affects the entire world and
that happens over the course of decades
but people live their lives at home or
in their town
and people live their lives day to day
so when you start talking about these
massive overwhelming changes
it can be really easy to just dismiss
them as either things
that don't affect me or things that i
can't do anything about
the idea of creating localized insights
and personally meaningful insights is
that we need to talk about climate
change in a way that's relevant
to the intended audience and so if we
can say for example
well here in boston the city was
actually considering building sea walls
because of anticipated flooding now all
of a sudden that's something that's
happening in my neighborhood
that's something that's like oh my god
that's coming for me
that's not the earth is warming by two
degrees celsius which doesn't really
mean much to me it's
oh my god there's going to be flooding
in boston
the more i talked with brandon the more
i wanted to know what was personally
motivating him
to engage in climate action work he
began to talk about the
intergenerational experiences
of his own family a few years ago
my family celebrated its 25th
anniversary in the united states
we were all at my grandparents place
seated around this beautiful dining room
table
in front of a gorgeous display case full
of fancy china
and my grandma was bustling around
making sure we all had enough of that
fatty and meaty ukrainian food that my
family loves
and my family was telling stories
stories of my childhood that i'd been
hearing for years
but stories that helped us reflect on
what it meant to come to the united
states
my grandpa told how he'd only taken one
flight in his whole life
and it was to come to the united states
because the only thing that he feared
more than flying was staying in a
collapsed soviet state
my grandma how she came to the u.s
without knowing any english and not only
learned english but also learned how to
code
and recently retired as a senior
software developer
my mom how she after four months here
was caught stealing a seven dollar
bottle of face cream
because she wanted to get a gift for her
mom's birthday and she couldn't afford
it
now my mom went on and started a
business that ended up putting me
through college
but even 25 years later she was still so
embarrassed and ashamed of that moment
i turned to my dad and i asked him
whether he ever missed
the ukraine it's where he grew up it's
where his friends
are and he turned to me and responded in
russian
that only in his worst nightmare would
he ever wake up back in that hell
and to me that moment really
crystallizes this idea that so much
of who we are and what we have is
determined
by choices that people make before we're
even born and that's just
such a great injustice and
climate change exemplifies that i think
climate change is
one of the great injustices of our time
it was created primarily by wealthy
privileged people in developed nations
and it will primarily affect the
vulnerable the poor
the sick in many cases people who never
even contributed to the problem
i think that for those of us who have an
opportunity
to fight that injustice for those of us
who have benefited
from being fortunate and from being born
in the right place at the right time
we have a real obligation to help the
people
who don't necessarily have those
opportunities now reach those same
opportunities
and in this case it means doing
something about
this massive global problem that will
eventually affect all of us but is
already affecting
many of the most vulnerable
one important component in tackling
climate change
is recognizing that it's a collective
issue that affects just about everyone
brandon incorporated interactive
activities into the climate 101
curriculum
to help simulate how these collective
dilemmas can play out
these activities are modeled on the
concept of the tragedy of the commons
where people tend to act selfishly when
they believe that their individual
actions
won't make an impact a classic example
of the tragedy of the commons
is the gradual overfishing of a public
waterway
and in some ways this concept mirrors
what we've seen throughout the kovit 19
pandemic
while these issues are quite different
of course they do both require
collaborative efforts to make a real
difference in tackling them
and our everyday choices actually can
have an immediate impact
i think covid is a really great example
of collective dilemmas
and in the us in particular we have this
very individualist attitude
personal liberty above all else and
personal liberty is
obviously super important but we see in
a case like kovid
that when crises arise sometimes
we do need to act for the collective
good and that can be really difficult
but climate change is similar the longer
we waited to take action on kovid
the more drastic the action had to be
and with climate change it's similar
had we started really focusing on
reducing our emissions and transitioning
to renewable energy
as well as making some of the other
changes we need to make in
2000 we could have done it pretty
gradually and at a reasonable pace
but we waited 20 years and it looks like
we're still waiting
so now the action that we have to take
is much more drastic
than had we done it 20 years ago and if
we continue to wait
that action will have to be still more
drastic
so yesterday is better than today and
today is better than tomorrow
to quote one of the articles that i read
regarding kovid
but that also applies equally well to
climate change
many people worry that attention on
climate change has weakened due to the
covet 19 pandemic
but brandon sees a space for optimism
and views these overlapping crises
as an opportunity i think for a lot of
climate activists right now is
difficult in terms of climate activism
because
covet is a really serious and really
urgent problem
and it can be hard to spare any
attention or any emotion
for climate change this other scary
thing but times of crisis are actually
times of opportunity
and so right now is a time that people
feel like they need connection and
purpose
and community and so right now is an
opportunity for us to continue growing
and giving people those things and it's
also an opportunity to fight even harder
for some of the changes that we need to
make in order to
overcome the climate change issue as
well as the covet issue
much of brandon's work around this
project which inspires others to take a
leadership role in their own way
has been driven by his own experiences
with leaders in his life
throughout the covet 19 pandemic he's
found strong leaders and his advisor
professor david newman at mit
who you heard from in our last episode
and rand wentworth
brandon's environmental leadership
professor at the harvard kennedy school
they have both been such incredible
models of what it means to be a leader
during a crisis
they have been hyper attentive to their
students needs
so empathetic such good listeners
adaptive and flexible and positive
and that has been really inspiring for
me
empathy is everything and it's just so
hard right now
you know my emotional reserves that i
usually
use to accomplish tasks that i don't
necessarily find is interesting
are gone at this point i'm just hyper
focused on staying sane
staying happy staying healthy and
rand and deva both really understand
that and they start every meeting
with a check-in how are you guys what
can i do to help
and that's something that i hope to take
forward
as an immediate response in a crisis
is to figure out okay how are the people
that are affected by this crisis
doing and what can i do to accommodate
them and to make it easier
for them brandon understands that many
people
when faced with the covet 19 pandemic as
well as the threat of climate change are
experiencing a kind of
doom fatigue if you seek it out there
can be an
overwhelming amount of bad news about
both crises
but brandon is working on reframing this
thinking into something more
approachable
so that people can carry forward with
important work in their own
manageable way without feeling like it's
all just too much to handle
there are definitely times when i also
feel like
why am i even bothering there's so
much out there to improve
what can i do there's a story
that i love it's
told by wangari matai who's a nobel
peace prize winner
for her environmental work she tells the
story
of a great big forest fire and how all
of the animals
are running out of the forest and
they're standing next to it
as it burns but one animal the
hummingbird
starts going to a nearby lake and
carrying
one drop of water at a time to douse the
forest fire
and all the other animals are asking
what are you doing you're so small
this fire is so big you can't possibly
do anything
about it the elephant is standing there
with its big trunk
all the other animals that are also much
bigger just doing nothing
the hummingbird keeps on going and then
finally
without missing a beat the hummingbird
says
i'm doing the best i can
and when gary mattai says we should all
be like hummingbirds
we should all just do the best that we
can and some days that's not
very much at all and that's okay but we
should all remember
that we each can do something and that
that matters
and that that's enough in that moment
in our individual work on climate change
it's okay to take the approach of the
hummingbird to make a difference
if you're interested in becoming an
earth dna ambassador or want to learn
more about their training program and
materials
head to earthdna.org ambassadors
you can also find the climate 101
presentation slides
a video of brandon giving the
presentation ambassador program
application
handouts and volunteer resources on our
mit open courseware website
and by the way did you know
opencourseware is turning 20
it's taken a community to bring ocw to
this moment
and we want you to be a part of it and
what comes next
please join us for a virtual celebration
of ocw's impact
community and the future of open sharing
on wednesday april 7th
2021 at 12 pm eastern time you can
register using the link in our show
notes
or just tune in live to ocw's youtube
instagram or facebook pages
thank you for making these first two
decades possible and thanks so much for
listening to the chalk radio podcast
until i see you on april 7th signing off
from cambridge massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen from mit opencourseware
mom passed the car